[Musique]
père céleste
puissions-nous être vos outils afin de
réparer ce que nous trouvons prise et
j'ai su créé
[Musique]
une jeune femme et sa fille de 15 mois
ont été assassinés chez elle
nous demandons l'aide de toute la
population nous ne sommes pas une
communauté ayant pour habitude de
verrouiller une porte
mais nous estimons qu'il serait
désormais prudent de faire preuve de
vigilance
l'épreuve révèlerait des pratiques et
les croyances
donc je n'avais que très rarement quand
tu parles
je ne faut jamais dépassé
vous devriez en faire autant
à la seconde quelqu'un pousser son
regard sur elle
il était sous son charme
il y a une présence démoniaque pour sa
fille et suit ce dossier ne se résume
pas au noir et qui s'en prend à sa femme
ce soit dès que le tout premier signe
d'une valise
qui s'était finalement frayer un chemin
tortueux soltes notre désert
ça va au-delà du simple odeur ça va au
delà de tout ce en quoi je crois